you're welcome to this 15-minute game
plan fo for change against relics from
the US 93 yeah okay one down let's play
the open and see ya knight c6 years some
relatively rare move it it's not bad
actually just a bit uncommon to play to
play this so early yeah white has rather
wide range of setups guess let's go we
should be three decide later how to put
put the rest especially the bishop on
everyone I have rarely played Bishop c4
setups against a sicilian i wonder if
this is a good idea here he might have
Knight to g4 the Sun could be a bit of
an annoyance I could play Bishop e2 just
a covering g fo I can play f3 yeah maybe
f3 going for the English attack setup
kept blacks my choice now asleep on move
it one square move it 2 squares there
are not at all play g6 so he moved them
it's two squares yeah yes yes 2b3 yeah
yeah he's some intending to play d5 and
I have two main ideas to counter that I
can play Knight to g5 on or maybe g-form
g45 so g4 g5g five but I think it can
play deform which looks out the Doug
leaf for me so probably Eddie took on 95
if it takes with the bishop he takes
Knight hmm e seven maybe just maybe see
form yeah much else yeah okay yeah well
now a scout them this is actually
interesting he could also consider to go
to to be eight sometimes this is a good
idea to have the night on this happen
later and not only seven words sometimes
clocks up your pieces well d 5 is no
hanging and I need to react to that so
it will go see form and this is a fairly
typical structure which very often
arises in the Sicilian wear white puts
knight on d5 and it is taken the only
thing that I don't like so much is that
I have played f three years looks a bit
this looks a bit weakening
the question is where to put the bishop
now maybe I'll d3e to us of the more
common square but on d3 I prevent Knight
to f5 which looks so rather annoying
okay so this was so cam
night to g6 yeah it is helpful that he
won't get in g6 at five quickly yeah
Quran probably I need to cancel anyway
yeah now we will play yeah the smooth
and how do I continue I i go here
intending night a five-night a 5 + B
form to use the beep on I have this four
against three majority so in the long
run be four point to be four pawn to c5
is what I'm what I'd like to to achieve
night to h5 yeah okay you want wants to
go to 2f form and the question is should
I prevent that after night f4 maybe he
can even play Bishop g5 later so I kind
of like this direct way to to stop it
yeah now Blackham might go f5f5f5 that's
not so so comfortable I cannot easily
prevent f5 Bishop f5 for example or
taking the rookie just takes on c4 and
this wasn't wanting to plan really hmm
yeah it's not so easy off non f form the
reply f4 or f5 f4 is a good idea take
stakes and then um yeah this is good
need to prepare that get out of them out
of the range of some pieces King to h1
so f 5 i'm going to play a form and he
cannot easily move the e porn taking on
air for advancing as this would allow
night to d 436 but you just retreat this
is weird it doesn't really fit with the
rest of of the position you need to get
counterplay cannot just hang around ok 9
a-5 attacking the porn on b7 and
intending before yeah this is this a
second player should be six yeah
probably i should it is sometimes the
thing is if you are have some experience
in
in some positions here I've got points
on f.3d 5 and ce4 there are on light
squares and the dark squared Bishop
Bishop is a very important piece um if
you give up this Bishop against let's
say yeah blacks bishop for example if
these bishops would exchange then it
would be a very very good for black
because my dark squares are are
seriously weakened and now we are this
way I will in exchange I saw it
immediately but you need to really
consider it from you want to win
material and give up the bishop because
it is always some a bit of a problem
that your dark squares are also so
weakened okay in this case I think I
should I should take and it's not it's
nothing immediately apparent here yeah I
thought before now but does the night go
maybe to e4 but this Bishop on f5 was
just just there to prevent him from
playing f5 himself yeah so look maybe I
rook see one again maybe yeah but age 6
I always have f4 if he goes Bishop g5
hmm
pawn to c5 would be nice if I would
manage to to get this in yeah come on
Roxy one that some it's fine h6 we
should be five I always have a form
there's simply no threats
yeah c5 now takes a ir s house i also
have d 67 136 opposite to see to
attacking the the night night will be
six only move and Bishop b3 added c5
next moves here come on this is also
good and now I'm coming with c5 next
move
97 or maybe okay come on
yep and now I've got a very very nice d
porn and his pieces are are really not
coordinated in any kind of way so just
be seven just take me seven right also
protects if I fan them I just intend to
take okay so this thing is hanging so I
take first and I'm going with g6
yeah two passports on the sixth-ranked
are really nice to have yeah yeah I
simply didn't didn't go for counterplay
this is the problem I think he played
this this quite ok on up to up to this
point but now after g three castles then
i went here and then 9 f 6 is the
problem this is really not going for for
for any kind of counter play yeah for
better or worse you need to play at five
at some point otherwise you can you
won't get anything maybe h6 could be it
could be an alternative we just put this
on quickly here i decided to play
painting edge one if you go at five then
my idea was to play a firm to play a
form so that in this position I have
this idea this is also why when King
edge one just out of out of things yeah
I'm allowing Brooke g1 at some point
stuff like that and this clears the the
news of the upon clears this path also
if he would go here this text and this
is this is over already too much
now another six is just passive but
maybe I'm maybe it may be h 6m could
could also be considered with this idea
but I have 95 it's this is really
annoying the smooth you probably don't
want to play this but maybe maybe I five
anyway therefore I now you don't need to
move the earth porn necessarily maybe
this will protect you have five I think
white um is a little bit better here but
it's not it's not the end of the world
black and black and play that at least
he's got some kind of influence in the
center and in this position now it's
it's rather one-sided of course EMP
should be 60 and ash that it's really
good to this version just grab the
exchange they probably needed to play
this and then my attention on was to to
play before maybe instantly maybe after
some preparation this kind of move kill
maybe something like this this is still
playable I mean it's not not down
overwhelming for white yeah thanks for
watching